you won't find standard flavors here
Pietro Samoa is colognes most creative
ice-cream maker he offers a wide variety
of unusual flavors like his newest
creation coconut sweet potato with
yogurt he got the idea one night during
dinner it's very sweet and the customers
seem to like it
Samara makes all his ice cream himself
today's featured flavor is mango one of
the most popular items on the menu here
at is gelateria the mangos are grown
organically and imported directly from
India when the ices the final product
has a very strong mango flavor and the
aroma of mangos it's great the mix of
fruit water sugar and a gelling agent is
stirred until it reaches the correct
consistency that usually takes about
seven minutes the Coco used here comes
from Virunga National Park in the
Democratic Republic of Congo some of the
proceeds are donated to the park we use
Coco from nature and then we give
something back to nature it's a
beautiful concept samuri seeks to uphold
the highest possible quality control
standards both for his ingredients and
the production of his ice cream his cafe
is located in the trendy part of
southern Cologne
he's been selling ice cream here for
four years he's always coming up with
new flavors always something different
right now my two favorites a mango and
passionfruit and if you like you can
order an espresso made with beans
roasted by another small Italian
business Pietro his wife helps him run
the cafe Pietro is a real perfectionist
and at first that was tough but I think
his perfectionism is partly what's made
us so successful you can see it in the
quality of our product Pietro Samaras
ice cream shop
another reason to visit Cologne
especially in the summertime